you don't need to be a hero to be a real
hero
[Music]
we jointly required it only for the nine
months of large-scale invasion 27 000
episodes of our crimes and 27 thousands
is a huge amount but it's only tip of
Iceberg I personally interviewed
hundreds of people who survived Russian
captivity and they told me horrible
stories how they were beaten how they
were raped how their fingers were cut
how their nails were turned away how the
nails were drilled how they were
tortured with electricity how they were
compelled to write something with their
own blood there is no military purpose
in doing inside things Russians have
done these horrible things only because
they could so we must break the circle
of impunity in order to do it we have to
fill the Gap accountability
into the sense that organization of
resistance and organization with City
management and occupied territories it
it is a no new experience and it is
those tasks that we cannot believe ever
that we will need to solve nobody clever
person in melaton agreed to give support
to Russia no one chief of school from 22
schools agreed to give support to
Russian no one chief of kindergarten
from 21 kindergarten military agreed to
give support from Russian know anyone
wise mayor know anyone chief of
Department nobody wants to
give or take Thompson is the same with
Russians all our citizens want to live
in Democratic Ukraine and the European
Union
[Music]
to recreate our organization as a tool
to help Ordinary People to save their
Ukrainian identity in occupation to see
if the Ukrainian mindset to help them to
find the way how they can be useful for
their country in this time because we
understand not all the people have this
opportunity to become a soldier or an
officer of the Ukrainian Armed Forces
but we give this tool
help to people make them understanding
that their work are needed by their
country you don't need to be a hero to
be a real hero
[Music]